نادر مميت ومرتبط بفيروس ايبولا هذا كل ما
نعرفه عن فيروس تم اكتشافه في دولتين
واقعتين على جانبي القاره السمراء ويسمى
ماربورج لكن الامر ليس مستغربا فمنذ ثلاث
سنوات اي عند انتشار فيروس كورونا عجز
الاطباء عن معرفه تفاصيل كامله او دقيقه
حول الفيروس لتاتي بعدها الدراسات التي
فسرت طريقه انتشاره وعوارضه
عموما تصيب فيروسات مثل كورونا ايبولا
ومار برج الحيوانات عاده وتنتشر الى
الاشخاص في بعض الاحيان لكن عدم معرفه
المصدر الحيواني الاصلي للعدوى يبقي مسارا
انتقال عدوى الفيروس للشخص غير واضح خبراء
الصحه رجحوا ان تكون اصابه الشخص الاول
بالعدوى نجمت عن التعامل مع حيوان مصاب
بالعدوى او اكله لتكون بدايه للطفره
الاولى منه لتنتقل العدوى بعدها من شخص
الى اخر اما باتصال مباشر بالجلد او
بسوائل كاللعاب او الدم وكما بدايات
كورونا مؤشرات عده اشارت الى انه لا يمكن
للاشخاص نقل العدوى قبل ظهور الاعراض
عليهم اما عن مرحله ما بعد الاصابه وبحسب
خبراء يقوم جهاز المناعه بالقضاء نهائيا
على الفيروس فيما يبقى لبعض الوقت في
مناطق من الجسم محميه من الهجمات من قبل
جهاز المناعه
اياد حمود العربيه